[Music
] No
, I'll get people, so I'm already a citizen of the prefecture
Oh, oh,
I'll start with my big term and make-up, so let's be fine at that time.
]
[music]
par
[applause] Then
I'll always be with you forever, even if I die, I'll protect Mi-chan no
ana
yeah yeah goo  um
tan
[music]
[applause]
par
boku ni
ani
click every day
ni
tan
ana
nba
[music]
me
te
[music]
umm
Onomatopoeia
car
me
[Applause]
[Music]
What's with the movement
?
I thought he'd change when he died He's
such a stubborn kid Even though
he was dizzy yesterday  Thread was delicious, but
it's 10 gold coins along the way
What's the
old tiger
?
I'm sorry
ah ah ah
[music]
[music] When
there
was Amakawa, I was a college student with a strong sense of the country called Japan
And then
probably died in a traffic accident
2nd axis
I don't know what that means No, I understand, but
no, this is a woman  I've been living in this dingy slum to avenge my enemies,
sister,
why is my mother's hair black?
My
father, grandpa, and grandma all had black hair.
Heh, I want to meet grandpa and grandma someday. When you grow up, I'll
take you there.
Promise
Pure
Mother
[Music]
Hey, I hope you don't get too close to me. It's not
bad for your
health.
Speak honestly
I don't think you'll be able to answer that question.
You're
gay
Rion a o It's a rare occasion I
guess that's
why your hair is black
By the way, there's something I want to ask you
Is the girl in the light purple group
I haven't seen it
days ahead?  It's not even outside, right
? White
What do you mean
, I have to go
look for that girl?
What kind of clothes do the women who live in
Tokyo wear?  We're moving in a non-regular
manner.It's not something Christina would want to get into a fuss with.
Please wait
Area edge
me
[music]
Has that child aged? It seems that a lot of magical
power is flowing from that child's body.
The flight distance is also good around
here, so there are no other reactions.The
only magic reactions that got caught in the search were us and that
child.  Can't you see the light that can read the
difference?
There's no time right now
Gordon, I'll teach you
how to use magic
, so I learned it with my
senses.
Light
is coming out of your body, isn't it?
Using light, your ability to advance and retreat, etc.
Physical joints
Strong water
Yeah, that's good, right?
[music]
4 days after
all
, I'm going to take it off now, so wait a minute and put me in the back
Can't you laugh please?
I'm in 7. In addition to this, the people who were looking for the
auction just now have come.
Asked by
adwords Please calm down Miss
Christina
Would you please tell me that's
why I was asked by that child?
Please read on
to provoke me.
It's not a request, it's an order
I only helped
that child.  If
only Akemi is innocent, he should be released
.
I'm the deputy commander of the Knights of the Imperial Guard, Charles Aru.
Don't be silly.
I don't want to do it too much.
I admit that you were complicit in the kidnapping of the Rhine little girl.
I didn't do that
.
Lesser: I
'm in the
professional's bedroom.
Lancer: Thank you. Could you
please explain what's going on?
In that case, please call him here.Is
that really
difficult?Yes,
that boy is only an orphan
once.I wonder if His Majesty's permission is necessary.Then
, please make the necessary arrangements as soon as possible.Fujii in
the shape of a leaf.  I won't let you do it during the day
Ah, I sent it to you, I'll be there
too.
If the Knights of the Imperial Guard kidnapped Lolo-sama, it would be fine if it was a
production system
.
I should have told my subordinates to interrogate this boy in a
courteous manner.  There's a
high possibility that Lady Flora said that the boy
was her benefactor, wasn't it?
I'm sorry I
surprised you.  Celia Give
me I remember the
area
[music]
Jean It's a
bountiful catch, so
thank
you for taking it.
]
What will happen to me from now on?
It seems that you would like to directly tell the employee about this matter
.
[Music]
Nice to meet you
[Music] From
now on, the boy who saved Princess Komura will enter.
com i i i i ana
me
[music]
tan
ni
[music]
gemani
[music
] profit er
[music]
royal academy
voodoo buff
2 n
[music]